hi i'm ria today a friend will be
challenging me to take a popular food
and
make it fancy who's the friend
it's jasmine let's see what she wants me
to make fancy today hey riya it's me
jasmine it's boba you know me i love
boba i love drinking it i love eating it
i'll have it in any size preferably an
extra large to me boba is not a trend it
is a way of life i've seen people do a
lot of unique takes on boba so i have
pretty high expectations but you're
really after all so i'm very much
looking forward to what you're going to
come up with good luck and goodbye
boba
i had a boba before i like boba but i'm
not a
huge fan of jasmine i
have a tripophobia trypophobia it's if
you see something small round thing
bunch of it makes me uncomfortable and
boba eats kind of have that vibe
i like kind of gummy texture i like the
chew i think jasmine is a tough guest to
please because she loves boba one
halloween she dress up like boffa too i
think she want to be a boba this is fine
right now it just makes me uncomfortable
i'm not gonna cry right
[Applause]
so this is made with tapioca starch if
it's not cooked it's quite hard there
are a lot of people making cool stuff
with boba i feel like jasmine has seen
it all so it's gonna be pretty hard to
impress her with something new but i
have some ideas and i'm excited to make
it fancy
right here's what i got eggs milk half
and half coconut flour almond flour
white chocolate and citric acid from the
pantry i got black tea apple cider
vinegar gelatin powder canola oil sugar
coconut oil baking soda salt cocoa
powder food coloring espresso powder
lemon extract and vanilla extract
alright let's get started
make it fancy boba edition
before we start we have new merch make
you fancy apron you can find it make it
fancy.com
[Music]
you can find at
shopmakeyfancy.com i have three and a
half tablespoons of gelatin glue this
you have to bloom it with cold water
first about five minutes and meanwhile
put water
and sugar
and citric acid citric acid is for
flavoring and also to make clear jelly
you don't want to boil this so this is
start getting a little bubble and
steamed so i'm going to take off from
the heat and add bloomed gelatine
lightly whisk lemon extract 1 teaspoon
and i learned making other video the cap
is actually 1 teaspoon so you can use
the cap gelatin is completely dissolved
to use large pitchers so i don't spill
adding
to round glass bowl
i'm gonna lay this down to room
temperature and chill in a refrigerator
about one hour i took out this gelatin
dome and i have yellow colored boba
pearl it's already cooked kind of want
to put in the center so using a stick
kind of push until
where you want it to be
we put this in a refrigerator about one
hour and a half so it's kind of
semi-settled if it's too
still runny and if the pearl is sinking
you can put it in the freezer about five
to ten minutes so things are
kind of floating in the middle i want to
set this gelatin dome fully set it will
take about six hours to overnight to be
safe i'm going to wait overnight and i
will see you tomorrow 24 hours later we
are back we are well rested there are
plenty of things to do so let's get
started one tablespoon gelatine powder
you know what you have to do gloom
gelatin and wait about five minutes heat
half cup of milk and sugar
you don't want to boil milk either you
just want to kind of let the sugar melt
it start getting like little bubbles i'm
gonna take off from the heat add broom
the gelatine
melt make sure the gelatin is completely
dissolved and then add rest of the milk
half cup so i'm adding white food
coloring makes
the other color pops or
side of the cup and the rest of the
mixture in different cup two three drops
of green food color into one third cup
of milk mixture
three
drops of pink it matches your spatula
yeah so it doesn't stain that was all
coordinated did you realize green was
green this is still a little bit too
warm so i'm going to cool down to room
temperature and move on to next step
bloom gelatin
with black tea lightly whisk
and i'm going to heat up more black tea
and sugar and you want to heat it up but
you don't want to boil make sure all the
sugar is melted right now there is a
boba shortage
i heard about this was it the ship that
caused it i think it's because jasmine
is eating too much bubba mean it's a
problem sugar has melt set aside and put
back the bloomed
gelatin gelatin is melted add half and
half creating boba flavor but jelly form
i'm going to put boba pearls on the
bottom of cake pans i just cook this
boba according to the package and pour
over milk tea
mixture and i'm going to set this in the
refrigerator until set about five hours
and we have plenty more things to make
it fancy it's room temperature now
and we have jelly dome and it has a
yellow boba
pearls inside i have special tools it's
almost look like a surgery and we also
have a syringe what if we make something
like non-edible
like i made fancy but it's not
food take out all the air
pull
so i have only one shot i cannot make
mistakes so please send me strings
maybe my hands are gonna shake i'm
making a little petals
i think this one was popular
and i always wanted to try
so what i'm trying to do is insert this
part and inject so i'm making kind of
like petal
oh but it's going it's it's
it's pretty as you can see from the top
everything is covered with pink so i
cannot see so i'm putting in a freezer
about one minute and come back and we're
going to keep going so the top layer
colored gelatin is set so i can easily
peel off it to look like a slime it
looks good about doesn't look like a
perfect flower shape so i'm going to fix
it hopefully same thing
gelatin in a slinch
nice okay it's looking good
like spill happens so it's still a
little bit difficult it's kind of
guessing like i clean the top so i'm
going to one more round with pink the
flower petal doesn't look even so i'm
going to
put more petal
i think this is good all right here's
what it looks like right now move on to
leaf
want to put like four or five leaves
yes
that's pretty yes
i had one shot i'm happy what it turned
thank you so much for sending me
strengths it worked and i'm going to set
this in the refrigerator about one hour
and while it's chilling i'm going to do
more stuff i have one cup water and i
have boba pearls bring this to a boil
and cook for 15 minutes is this
triggering
this one it's
not too bad i think once you
put in a mesh sieve it's a little bit
too much water came to a boil it smells
good and it's
becoming a little bit like something
makes me uncomfortable because it
absorbs the water and it become a little
bit big and it's expanded and there is
no space so
it's yeah let's get put in a blender
so i don't need to see it i'm fine i
just don't want to see something like
frog egg
don't google cover and you want to blend
until smooth
adding 3 4 cup of almond flour 1 egg 2
tbsp of coconut flour 6 tablespoons of
milk 2 tablespoons of canola oil half
cup of sugar half teaspoon of baking
soda half teaspoon of espresso powder 6
tablespoons of cocoa powder three
quarter teaspoon of apple cider vinegar
half teaspoon of vanilla extract quarter
teaspoon of salt blender cake blend
everything
i realized i didn't put water because
blender was
struggling quarter cup of water so
water's in and let's blend i'm making
gluten-free cake so you can make a lot
of gluten-free cake in blender because
gluten doesn't form don't use blender
when you're making regular cake because
it will ruin cake's texture it's gonna
be very gummy scrape the side make sure
everything is blending in smells so good
so i have six inch cake pan cut out six
inch parchment paper spray the pan
and pour
chocolate cake batter instead of tapioca
flour i use the boba pearls because it
made with tapioca bake this at 350 for
35 to 40 minutes or do the toothpick
test and comes out clean it's ready the
chocolate cake is baked and cold and i'm
going to cut them
you put this in a cake board so it's
easier to transfer and this is my boba
milk tea mousse just want to make sure i
can remove this from the pan easily so
i'm kind of scraping the side
and flip
i'm going to put hot water bowl
right here to something
[Music]
all right so it looks good this is the
jelly
dome i made earlier and i'm gonna just
peel off extra jelly on the surface so
my cake and milk jelly is assembled and
i'm going to take this off from tomorrow
since gelatin melts in a high heat
putting this in a warm water give a pass
my little jelly baby
push the side i'm just trying to release
the jelly from the mold all right we
only have one shot
i'm spreading my leg so i have a better
balance oh my god
look at this
don't break
yes i did it mom
[Laughter]
it could break in half and this is two
days process so i didn't want to make it
like four days process for everyone's
sake this is beautiful from the top the
cider is not fancy so
let's
make it fancy to hide imperfection i'm
going to
use white chocolate and coconut oil when
you are
doing some chocolate decoration coconut
oil helps to set make sure i use double
boiler so sugar doesn't burn chocolate
has melted pour this
into piping bag cut the tip
from here it's kind of free foam and i'm
kind of going saku
i think a little bit of like gap looks
nice this film is called acetate it's
very flexible plastic so it's very
helpful when you're making decoration
you can see the white chocolate color is
becoming a little bit opaque and it's
now ready to
going to press
against
and gently
press so it will stick together i'm
going to put this in the freezer about
five minutes so chocolate will set and
stick together and we will see the
moment of juice send me strength i take
off my cake with color from the freezer
and moment of truth
a little bit
yes
and we are done
boba jelly flower cake very fancy let's
see what jasmine thinks
hi jasmine hi
so i made a mini version for you
what
what
that is
insane really
your brain works in just like crazy ways
this is beautiful i i did not expect
this at all i mean i was expecting
something very fancy and very
extravagant each layer had some bobei
net bob in each layer good do you want
to cut the slice
oh my goodness it's kind of scary right
it's like it's like so delicate and like
i kind of don't even want to cut it
because it's so beautiful
nice nice slice all right
so i also got my slice bacho cheers
cheers
[Music]
is insane so jasmine did i make this
fancy you 100
made this super super fancy so there's
one thing left to do do you remember
it's been a while of course i remember
three two one make it
[Music]
you